bonjour à tous j'espère que vous avez
passé un bel été bienvenue dans mon
bureau dans le bureau de passer sauvage
c'est pas tous les jours que vous pouvez
le regarder si on commence ici c'est
parce que je vais vous présenter ce qui
s'affiche à mon écran il s'agit de
nextory qui sponsorise une nouvelle fois
une vidéo sur passé sauvage et Merci
beaucoup à eux de me faire confiance
nextory c'est une application de lecture
mais qui a la particularité de proposer
tous les formats podcast BD presse livre
audio ebook j'ai de nouveau épluché leur
catalogue et j'ai trouvé des choses
incroyables vraiment des surprises
notamment une collection qui s'appelle
les grandes voix co-édité avec le CNRS
ça a l'air génial je sais pas pourquoi
je connaissais pas ça avant il y en a un
sur le climat ce qui me suivent sur
Instagram savent que c'est un thème qui
m'intéresse énormément cette année
suivez-moi sur Instagram d'ailleurs si
vous voulez être tenu au courant de ce
qui va sortir il y en a un autre sur la
révolution néolithique bah oui ça très
bien on prend il y a du evaillous
pourquoi l'amour fait mal
on veut savoir ça a l'air très très bien
let's Godelier là suivre Jésus et faire
du business rien que pour le titre le
sens de la formule on y va et sinon
toujours dans cette fameuse collection
CNRS qu'on nous avait caché visiblement
qu'est-ce qu'on trouve du Christian
Ingrao et du Yoann chaputo moi je suis
pourquoi mon teint fan club ingra au
chaputo ce qui sont d'accord bah
mentionnez-vous en commentaire voilà
pour les découvertes je vous mets toutes
ces références dans la barre
d'information avec le lien évidemment
qui vous permet de tester cette
application vous avez trois abonnements
disponibles tous les détails sont très
bien expliqués sur l'application grâce à
ce lien qui s'affiche ici vous avez
accès à une période d'essai de 45 jours
offert au lieu de 14 habituellement sur
l'abonnement standard encore une fois
tout est très bien expliqué sur nextory
donc je vous souhaite une bonne
découverte une bonne lecture et on
enchaîne avec la vidéo du jour
[Musique]
il se trouve que les historiens les
anthropologues et les sociologues ont
pas mal de choses à dire là-dessus en
s'attachant à comparer à replacer dans
le contexte et à démêler les enjeux il
nous faut relativiser pas mal de choses
ce serait quand même dommage
d'abandonner ce sujet à la presse de
droite parce que le sujet n'est pas
toujours traité avec recul et nuance on
va pas se voiler la face bon ok on va
arrêter les calembours douteuses et vous
l'avez compris on va essayer aujourd'hui
de faire une rapides histoire du voile
et de ses différents usages bien sûr
toutes les sources sont en description
pour appuyer et prolonger ce qui est dit
dans la vidéo là puis sous la vidéo
venez pas me dire en commentaire qui a
pas les sources elles sont là sous la
vidéo merci il faut commencer par
l'essentiel c'est quoi un voile
en fait c'est à la fois simple et
compliqué le voile dans sa définition la
plus générale c'est un vêtement non
cousu qui couvre la tête c'est un paon
de tissu rien de plus mais il peut être
porté d'une infinité de manière couvrir
toute la tête seulement une partie ou
descendre sur le visage il peut être
transparent épais à jour et il peut y
avoir des plis des ornements ou même
plusieurs couches dans l'histoire le
voile a servi pour de nombreux usages
que ce soit pour les femmes ou pour les
hommes en fait le voile est un moyen
simple et commode d'instaurer une
distance entre soi et les autres par
exemple le port du chèche chez les
Touareg ne peut pas être expliqué que
par un aspect purement pratique pour se
protéger du sable et du soleil c'est
d'abord pour cacher son visage à ses
proches c'est le signe d'une
honorabilité face à un étranger le
dévoilement est plus aisé car il y a
moins d'enjeux à afficher un statut
social pour l’historien Nicole Pellegrin
le voile crée donc un espace d'autonomie
et d'estime de soi autour du corps qu'il
revêt en Europe pendant longtemps
rabattre un pan de tissu sur la tête
était un signe de deuil pour les hommes
et les femmes cela permettait de cacher
ses émotions et de porter sur soi la
gravité du moment aujourd'hui ça arrive
fichu foulard sèche turban bandana et
autres kéfiées sont des vêtements du
quotidien pour une grande partie de
l'humanité mais vous le savez ce ne sont
pas ces usages qui font du voile un
sujet sensible c'est davantage son
utilisation comme symbole religieux et
en particulier pour les femmes c'est
toujours sur nous que ça tombe pour
comprendre d'où vient cet usage
religieux et aussi pourquoi il s'est
imposé de manière aussi stricte sur le
corps des femmes il faut remonter à
l'Antiquité
[Applaudissements]
l'une des premières mentions d'un voile
imposé aux femmes provient d'une
tablette cunéiforme acierienne datée aux
alentours de 1100 avant Jésus-Christ
découverte à Assour dans le nord de
l'Irak actuel la table est en question
conserve plus de 750 lignes de textes et
détails en 59 articles le droit
matrimonial et le statut des femmes on y
apprend que les femmes mariées devaient
à cette époque avoir la tête couverte
dans l'espace public c'est une mention
rapide dont on connaît mal les contours
précis mais elle permet d'inscrire le
port du voile féminin dans une longue
tradition certaines ont la tête couverte
et d'autres non
et puis c'est tout et puis voilà bon
plus proche de nous en Grèce antique le
voile pouvait marquer un statut social
ou un moment particulier de la vie mais
il avait sans doute rien d'obligatoire
ni de signification très rigide on le
voit avec les tanagas ces petites
statuettes qui représentent le plus
souvent des femmes certaines ont la tête
couverte et d'autres non c'est plutôt
lors de moments importants que les têtes
se couvrent de tissu pour marquer la
peine pendant un deuil par exemple
l'autre moment décisif où les femmes se
voilent la tête en Grèce c'est lors de
leur mariage certains vases qui
représentent des mariages le montrent
très bien même s'il existe aussi des
mariages ou les femmes ont la tête nue à
l'issue de la cérémonie elles peuvent
offrir ce voile à une divinité notamment
era protectrice des femmes et déesse du
mariage le dévoilement devient ainsi une
métaphore du consentement la femme qui
se dévoile pour son époux accepte
symboliquement son sort c'est un prélude
à l'acte sexuel car le voile en Grèce
possède aussi une dimension érotique il
souligne le caractère désirable de la
femme qui le porte les ét les plus
nobles et des couleurs chatoyantes
certes à souligner le visage et les
courbes des jeunes femmes portaient plus
sobrement il devient le symbole du lien
entre une femme et son époux et il n'est
plus arboré par les veuves qui montrent
ainsi la fin de leur statut maritale un
peu plus tard dans la Rome antique le
voile sert aussi au moment du mariage
mais c'est avant tout un signe religieux
le fait de se couvrir la tête concernant
Rome tout le monde homme ou femme dès
lors qu'il s'agit de participer à un
rythme religieux contrairement au monde
grec où l'on sacrifie tête découverte
les prêtres romains sont ainsi désignés
par l'expression capitaine la tête
voilée les statues d'empereur tête
voilée soulignent ainsi leur rôle de
grand pontife chef de la religion en
train de réaliser un rite on le voit par
exemple sur certaines statues d'Auguste
ou sur la colonne Trajane où l'empereur
réalise le sacrifice avant son
expédition militaire l'Historia antique
plus tard explique cette habitude par le
besoin de s'empêcher de voir ou
d'entendre des signes de mauvaise augure
au moment d'accomplir le rythme en se
couvrant les yeux et les oreilles le
sacrifiant se entièrement à son rituel
chez les femmes romaines ce sont d'abord
les vestales qui portent le voile
prêtresse consacrée à Vesta la déesse du
foyer vivant recluse et chaste elle
porte un voile qui recouvre leur tête on
peut vraiment les considérer comme les
ancêtres des nonnes chrétiennes dans la
vie courante les femmes romaines portent
souvent une pala un voile qui s'avance
sur le haut du crâne mais laisse des
couverte la chevelure et les oreilles
mais cela n'a sans doute rien
obligatoire dans l'espace public en
revanche la coiffure représente un enjeu
bien plus important les vitae
bandelettes qui ornent les tresses
affirment le statut de femme mariée de
Matron et doivent être portés dans la
rue d'autres coiffures élégantes
marquant ce statut marital peuvent être
arborés tels que la Mithra a un
largement dos mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec la foire religieuse avant le
christianisme
[Musique]
car tout change avec le christianisme
cette nouvelle religion qui se diffuse
dans l'Empire romain cherche à prendre
ses distances avec le judaïsme dont elle
est issue car dans la Bible hébraïque le
texte sacré des Juifs le voile n'est
jamais mentionné comme un vêtement
religieux on l'évoque seulement au
moment du mariage de Rebecca Isaac dans
une tradition qui ressemble au mariage
grec ou romain rien de spécial donc mais
les chrétiens en font un vêtement bien
plus important dans la première épître
au Corinthiens qui fait partie du
Nouveau Testament chrétien l'apôtre Paul
le véritable organisateur de la doctrine
chrétienne recommande le port d'un voile
aux femmes mariées il écrit toute femme
qui prie ou qui prophétise la tête non
voilée déshonore sa tête elle est comme
celle qui est rasée si une femme ne se
voile pas la tête qu'elle se coupe aussi
les cheveux or si les honteux a une
femme d'avoir les cheveux coupés ou la
tête rasée qu'elle se voile l'homme ne
doit pas se couvrir la tête parce qu'il
est la gloire de Dieu tandis que la
femme et la gloire de l'homme ce n'est
pas l'homme qui a été créé pour la femme
mais la femme pour l'homme bon pour ce
qui est de l'égalité des sexes on
repassera mais le message au moins le
mérite d'être clair la Bible chrétienne
invente l'obligation du voile pour les
femmes et j'ai un peu la voix voilée
vous m'excuserez dans les premiers temps
du christianisme d'autres théoriciens
religieux insistent sur cette nécessité
Clément d'Alexandrie au début du
troisième siècle écrit il est prescrit
aux femmes de se couvrir la tête et de
se voiler le visage c'est qu'il n'est
pas conforme à la volonté divine que la
beauté du corps soit un piège à capturer
les hommes dans cet esprit ce n'est pas
aux hommes de maîtriser leurs pulsion
mais c'est aux femmes objets désirable
de se cacher des hommes pour éviter
d'être agressé
mais attention il ne faudrait pas que le
voile ne devienne aussi un outil de
séduction après tout on l'a vu c'était
souvent le cas en Grèce notre moraliste
chrétien se dépêche donc d'ajouter et il
n'est pas non plus raisonnable qu'une
femme porte un grand voile pourpre pour
attirer les regards donc en voile mais
pas trop grand et pas trop coloré le
dress Scott se complique cette
impérative du voile féminin est encore
élargie par tertulien un auteur chrétien
qui écrit aussi au troisième siècle dans
le voile des vierges il conseille à
toutes les femmes vierges ou mariées de
porter un long voile tombant jusqu'à la
taille il précise que c'est absolument
indispensable à l'intérieur d'une église
mais que cela devrait aussi être le cas
dans l'espace public en général en
employant les termes de velamen et
velamen toum on peut considérer comme
l'historien Christophe Badel que
tertulien invente véritablement la
notion de voile telle que nous la
comprenons aujourd'hui dans ce texte on
lit notamment il faut voiler nos vierges
dès qu'elles sortent de l'enfance
l'obligation du voile commencera pour
elle le jour où elle peut exciter la
convoitise des hommes qui que vous soyez
mère sœur fille épouse n'importe l'âge
et l'état voilez votre tête c'est le
Christ qui veut que les épouses et les
fiancés des hommes soient voilés le
voile doit envelopper les épaules car ce
sont les épaules qui doivent être
soumises le voile et le jou des femmes
c'est bien on constate ici le changement
total de signification du voile pour les
Romains la tête couverte était une
marque de dignité pour une mère de
famille chez les chrétiens elle devient
une obligation de pudeur et même un
signe de soumission à l'homme voilà
voilà
[Musique]
dans le monde musulman le port du voile
existe dès l'origine ça vient du fait
que les vêtements amples et couvrant
étaient largement répandus chez les
tribus arabes et au Moyen-Orient en
général on le voit par exemple sur les
reliefs funéraires de Palmyre qui datent
des deuxième et troisième siècle après
Jésus-Christ et on a parlé au début de
la vidéo des traditions à syriennes bien
plus anciennes pourtant paradoxalement
le Coran est très laconique sur le sujet
la question du voile pour les femmes
n'était évoquée que très rapidement et
de manière assez vague à deux occasions
seulement tout d'abord dans la sourate
24 verset 31 et commande aux croyantes
de nous montrer de leur beauté que le
strict apparent qu'elle ramène leur qui
marche sur la poitrine difficile de
savoir précisément ce qu'on entend par
Kimar au septième siècle mais cela peut
sans doute être rapprochée d'un fichu ou
d'un foulard on le voit c'est loin
d'être inflexible ça rappelle plutôt une
nécessité de pudeur vis-à-vis des hommes
adultes qui n'appartiennent pas à la
famille le deuxième passage utilise un
autre terme celui de jilbab ce grand
vêtement drapé informe qui peut être
ramené sur la tête prophète dit à tes
femmes à tes filles et aux femmes des
croyants de ramener sur elle un pan de
leur djilbab elles en seront plus vite
reconnues et éviteront d'être offensés
ce passage là a l'air un peu plus
stricte mais cela pourrait aussi bien
être compris comme un conseil et pas
forcément une obligation le pain de
tunique relevé sur la tête peut être à
la manière d'un sari indien et censé
distinguer les femmes musulmanes des
autres femmes dans ses premiers temps de
l'islam afin qu'elle soit respectée en
tant que tel voilà ce sont les deux
seuls mentions du voile pour les femmes
dans le texte tout le reste le code
vestimentaire punitif et les tenues
intégrales sont des constructions
postérieures en Islam la grande majorité
des règles de vie ne proviennent en fait
pas des versets du Coran mais des
hadites les paroles orales du Prophète
rapportaient à postériori les historiens
spécialistes considèrent aujourd'hui que
ces paroles ont été forgées et réunis
bien plus tard environ 100 ans après la
mort du Prophète au début du 8e siècle
ses paroles reflètent donc les
traditions en train de se mettre en
place après plusieurs générations plutôt
qu'une vision prophétique originelle en
réalité le port du voile devient un
objet d'attention pour les savants
musulmans des siècles suivants qui
interprètent le texte sacré pour
répondre aux enjeux de leur époque c'est
au fur et à mesure que le port d'un
voile couvrant la tête et le visage à
l'extérieur de la maison va devenir une
obligation pour les femmes l'explication
donnée par plusieurs auteurs musulmans
du Moyen-Âge pour justifier cette
innovation et le harcèlement que
subissent les femmes Alsa marchahari un
exégète du Coran qui a vécu au début du
12e siècle dit par exemple les jeunes
gens et les hommes qui courent les
filles harcèlent les femmes lorsqu'elles
vont dehors on a donc ordonné à celle là
de se distinguer de leur servante par
leur tenue de s'envelopper la tête et le
visage en sorte qu'elle soit à l'abri de
tout harcèlement là ça y est c'est
obligatoire alors ça part peut-être
d'une bonne intention à savoir protéger
les femmes mais la conséquence c'est que
la contrainte pèse sur elle et pas sur
les hommes qui les harcèlent exactement
comme dans le texte chrétien de Clément
d'Alexandrie ce sont les femmes qui
doivent se cacher et les hommes qui les
importunent ne sont pas du tout
inquiétés
la comparaison du voile dans le
christianisme et l'islam point un
paradoxe celui d'évolution complètement
opposée le Coran ensemble assez peu
concerné par la question du voile et ne
délivre en fait pas d'obligation stricte
pourtant le voile est devenu au fil du
temps une injonction péremptoire dans la
plupart des pays d'Islam au contraire le
christianisme part d'une position très
rigide celle de l'apôtre Paul et des
pères fondateurs qui veulent absolument
voiler les femmes mais elle s'assouplit
petit à petit et tombe en désuétude en
fait on le voit un texte ça s'interprète
c'est ce que les institutions
religieuses ou civiles ont toujours fait
pour le christianisme le voile féminin
ne correspondait pas vraiment au
coutumes européennes est né devenu
l'apanage que des religieuses celles qui
se consacrent entièrement à la religion
c'est un uniforme religieux par contre
c'est vrai qu'en dehors du couvent le
voile n'est plus vraiment porté par les
femmes chrétiennes après le moyen-âge
juste au moment de la communion et du
mariage mais ce n'est plus un enjeu pour
les chrétiens l'interprétation et l'US
ont finalement contredit ce point de
doctrine pourtant c'est bien écrit dans
le bouquin au 16ème siècle le théologien
protestant Calvin l'a bien compris il
est moins attaché au voile en lui-même
car rappeler l'infériorité des femmes
dans ces commentaires sur l'épître au
corps indien il explique que selon lui
il faut une marque et un signe par
lesquels la femme montre qu'elle est
sous l'autorité du mari or ce signe là
c'est la tête couverte par un chaperon
un couvre-chef ou une coiffe ou tout
autre chose semblable en fait peu
importe ce qu'elle se met sur la tête
tant que cela symbolise leur soumission
voilà cela témoigne d'un certain
pragmatisme calvincey les mœurs ont
changé on ne peut pas imposer aux femmes
européennes du 16e siècle de porter un
voile qui cache leur visage comme dans
l'Antiquité il faut donc en prendre acte
mais préserver l'essentiel la domination
masculine le voilà l'enjeu finalement
c'est pas le texte sacré Bible ou Coran
on l'a toujours tordu dans tous les sens
pour lui faire dire ce qu'on voulait
et c'est normal on fait pareil avec les
textes de loi un même mot peut être
compris dans deux sens différents à 100
piges d'écart l'enjeu au bout du compte
c'est la domination des femmes par les
hommes le texte sacré n'est qu'un
prétexte pour justifier un système
patriarcal après ça prend des formes
plus ou moins pénibles Calvin et plus
soft que les Mola iraniens c'est certain
mais bon le voile instrument domination
masculine c'est pas forcément une
fatalité
[Musique]
peut-être interprété très différemment
même chose dans l'Islam aujourd'hui
certaines intellectuels comme la
sociologue marocaine fatima Mernissi ou
l'historienne Latifa Lakhdar qui a été
ministre de la Culture de Tunisie
veulent adopter une interprétation plus
égalitaire du Coran selon elle la vision
originelle du prophète Mohamed a été
modifié par l'influence de Oumar le
deuxième calife et véritable
organisateur du texte sacré ce serait
lui qui aurait conduit à une vision très
inégalitaire dans le Coran au contraire
le Prophète Mohammad aurait pu faire
preuve d'une certaine modernité étant
attentif aux critiques formulées par ses
épouses et ayant prononcé des paroles
plutôt favorables aux droits des femmes
il faudrait ainsi déceler l'influence
néfaste doumar pour l'atténuer et
retrouver un message plus authentique
des fameux hadiths ces paroles
rapportées du Prophète sont aussi
convoquées dans ce sens le roi du Maroc
Mohammed VI a par exemple rappelé dans
un discours qui date de 2003 qu'il
souhaitait adopter une formulation
moderne en lieu et place des concepts
qui portent atteintes à la dignité et à
l'humanisme de la femme à cet égard mon
aïeul le Prophète Sidna Mohamed a dit
les femmes sont égales aux hommes au
regard de la loi le roi du Maroc fait
référence ici à Hadit qui va dans un
sens égalitaire et qui peut appuyer un
changement de couture sur le voile ou
sur autre chose donc selon l'état
d'esprit et la volonté politique il sera
possible de trouver des éléments
religieux pour étayer des décisions
finalement on le voit le voile n'est pas
une affaire de religion ou bien à la
marge c'est d'abord une question
politique et c'est pour ça que c'est un
objet aussi conflictuel cela parle
d'abord de la place des femmes dans la
société et de leurs droits
[Musique]
on l'a vu dans christianisme comme dans
l'islam le port du voile est pensé comme
nécessaire pour protéger les femmes pour
les cacher pour interdire la vue pour ne
pas qu'elle soit importunée c'est tout
le paradoxe aujourd'hui dans les
sociétés européennes ou le voile au
contraire rend visible d'autant plus
lorsqu'il est intégré cela transforme
même celle qu'il le porte en cible
d'insultes ou de discrimination de la
part de ceux qui veulent interdire un
tel vêtement face à cette injonction de
se dévoiler porter un voile devient une
affirmation de la liberté un acte de
résistance passive voire une manière de
se comporter en martyrs d'endosser les
critiques pour prouver sa foi le voile
peut ainsi devenir une forme de
modernité religieuse comme on l'avait
évoqué dans une vidéo précédente en nous
appuyant sur les travaux du sociologue
raphaël Liogier l'interdiction tant
voulu par certains et donc totalement
contre-productive en plus d'être
arbitraire mais s'ils veulent peut être
un marqueur identitaire librement choisi
en Occident il reste aussi un instrument
de domination quand il est imposé par
les patr le cas les plus rétrogrades
depuis l'année dernière ces résistances
ont même viré à l'insurrection après
qu'une étudiante de 22 ans Massa Amini
arrêté au motifs d'un voile mal porté a
été battu à mort par la police des mœurs
le 16 septembre 2022 le voile est devenu
le symbole de l'oppression du régime de
nombreuses femmes se sont affichées
têtes nues ou se coupant les cheveux et
des hommes se sont aussi mis à porter le
voile par solidarité avec elle une
manière de défier ouvertement le régime
pour finir il faut dire qu'il n'y a pas
de morale à cette histoire ce n'est pas
mon rôle que de distribuer des bons ou
des mauvais points mais juste de pointer
les paradoxes et de préciser le contexte
historique il faut juste rappeler que ce
vêtement a une histoire complexe et
qu'il a toujours été un symbole
extrêmement puissant pour marquer un
deuil ou le respect des dieux par
exemple lorsqu'il est imposé aux femmes
par certaines sociétés au prétexte de la
religion il est aussi le symbole de la
domination masculine mais c'est pas une
fatalité voilà il y aura encore une
infinité de choses à dire vous vous en
doutez on a finalement parlé que une
partie du monde on a à peine effleuré
l'ensemble des significations qu'on peut
attribuer à ce vêtement on n'a pas parlé
de la mode de la symbolique mortuaire
pour les religieuses chrétiennes ou même
de tout l'imaginaire colonial
orientalisant qui a fantasmé le voile
des femmes musulmanes depuis le 19e
siècle mais vous le savez c'est une
vidéo on fait des choix pour essayer
d'aller à l'essentiel et vous avez toute
la bibliographie en barre d'information
si vous voulez creuser merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cet épisode avant de se
quitter j'ai une annonce à faire nous
publions ce livre avec Lucas pacote
alors de quoi s'agit-il si vous avez
aimé les formats cours les fameux coup
dur ce livre devrait vous plaire il
reprend en fait certains des thèmes
comme Hannibal Antoine et Cléopâtre
alors les développants donc ça devrait
aussi plaire à ceux qui étaient antiches
là ouais je vous vois je sais que vous
êtes par ici plus sérieusement si je
devais résumer ce livre je vous dirais
que c'est le livre qu'on aurait aimé
avoir en montrant à l'université avec
Lucas donnez en peu de mots les clés
d'événements emblématiques et de thèmes
importants de l'histoire antique en bref
essayez de se réapproprier la culture
générale vous pouvez le commander ici et
je vous invite à me suivre sur Instagram
et Twitter pour connaître les événements
prévus autour du livre merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cet épisode n'hésitez
pas à le partager à le liker à le
commenter et on se retrouve dans 15
jours pour mission à bientôt salut
[Musique]